en 1947 una naciente organización de las
naciones unidas propone el fin del
mandato británico
dividiendo palestina en dos estados
independientes uno árabe y otro judío
poniendo a jerusalén bajo el dominio
internacional fue la primera de una
larga lista de resoluciones sobre el
conflicto en 1967 israel ocupó jerusalén
este- provocando un nuevo éxodo de
palestinos la onu responde con una
resolución que establece los principios
de una paz justa y duradera en 1973 una
nueva resolución pide negociaciones
pacíficas al año siguiente se reafirma
el derecho del pueblo palestino al
retorno y a la independencia seguido del
primer levantamiento masivo contra la
ocupación israelí así como los acuerdos
de oslo en 1993 la segunda intifada en
2000 2005 y la más reciente la operación
´plomo fundido´ un asalto militar de 22
días a la franja de gaza- 2012 se
concede a palestina el estatus de
observador no miembro de naciones unidas
en 2016 el consejo de seguridad reafirma
que los asentamientos israelíes
son una violación flagrante del derecho
internacional durante décadas las
innumerables reuniones de la onu sobre
este conflicto han dado la impresión de
un fracaso global pero sin naciones
unidas- la situación sería probablemente
mucho peor preparándose para dejar su
puesto en diciembre como coordinador
especial de la onu para la paz de
oriente medio el búlgaro nikolai
mladenov insistió en que el objetivo de
una paz justa y duradera de los pueblos
israelí y palestino sobre la base de dos
estados sigue siendo inalcanzable